let's jump into audience questions for
the week first one is from Farah who
said hey David what's sketchy but legal
business tactics should people be aware
of very good question we've been asked
before about scams so this is not about
specific scams like multi-level
marketing or pseudoscience scams or that
type of thing but about specific tactics
that it's good for people to be aware of
number one contracts right so this
applies to a lot of different services
that we sign up for it will often not be
made clear unless you look at the fine
print whether the price you are being
offered number one is a temporary price
and number two whether it is a contract
that you were committing to or else have
to pay an early termination fee it is
very very common that with cable
companies and mobile phone companies
you'll be offered a price of say 50
bucks a month but that price is good if
you commit to 24 months of service if
you want to cancel short of the 24
months you will have to pay an early
termination fee if you don't want a
contract at all it might be 80 not
$50.00 very very common important
important for people to know about that
we hear every time we do these
discounted memberships I make it very
clear you keep the discounted price as
long as you want not that this was an
opportunity that fara created to pitch
membership but I'm super upfront about
that right it's not a low introductory
price the low low low introductory price
of only whatever when we do a discounted
membership you can keep that if you
decide hey you know what I don't need to
discount anymore then you can you can
choose to increase the price really
really common thing important to be
aware of that number two I know that
when it comes to like software terms and
conditions no one's gonna read that we
were asked do I ever read the Terms and
Conditions when I'm using some piece of
software or an app I really don't and I
probably should other times when you are
actually signing a contract that in much
more direct ways can influence your life
you will sometimes hear from people
listen you don't have to read this whole
thing we it's just something the legal
department gave us we don't ever really
enforce it it's really important to know
that you are assuming a lot of risk if
you are taking someone's word that
they're not going to enforce the
contract that you're about to sign a
good response if they say we don't
really enforce this is great then I
don't even really need to sign it right
and if the answer is yes then there's
the reason that that's the language
you're signing on to this can happen
with car leases this can happen with
employment related stuff this can happen
with settlements anytime a big
corporation or even a not so big
corporation is involved all that matters
is what you sign and I think it's really
important to be aware of that the other
really sketchy business tactic I wanted
to mention relates to collection
agencies and it often will prey on
people who are grieving after a loved
one has died and you'll get a phone call
from someone saying listen such-and-such
had this debt and you know it would be
really important that you do what they
would have wanted you to do and agree
that you'll assume this debt never ever
ever say yes if you were approached
about something like that it is
completely legal for them to ask you
even if it's in a state of grief if you
will assume that debt and if you say yes
it will be recorded that will now be
your debt so you never want to do that
so obviously no is it just forgiven then
the problem well it's not forgiven but
at least they now aren't going to be
saying hey you agreed to take over this
debt right it would have to work itself
through a process when the estate of the
deceased goes into probate etc etc
you're under no obligation to pay a debt
of a deceased person in almost any
situation there can be specific spousal
situations that are different I'm not an
estate attorney in case anyone was
confused but yet that's never ever ever
say that you were gonna take on and in
fact that is a general thing that you
should apply anytime a collection agency
calls you you should never agree to
anything over the phone and you should
say send me something in writing
validating the debt is what collections
people who understand how collection
agencies work will say is asks please
send me a validation of the debt in
writing and never agree to anything on
the phone so I have an interesting story
and it relates to what we're talking
about now yes always good I'm going to a
big-name gym and I'm actually trying to
you know go to a new place because I
found a place that's smaller closer to
my home less expensive sure so I tell
this gym that I'm going to be cancelling
and
you know I assume it's gonna be good for
the next month they say no because you
didn't give us 15 days notice right so
you actually have to pay through the
next month I'm like ah man I really
don't want to do that yeah so my first
thought was what if I just cancel the
card right it's hooked up to a debit
card they don't have my social security
number right I can just you know cancel
the card and I won't have to worry about
making the next payment and I was gonna
do that but then I realize like you know
what if this $44 that I owe goes to a
collections agency it's probably it's
gonna be a bigger hassle I might as well
just eat the $44 yeah and the the
collections agency thing in and of
itself isn't necessarily the biggest
issue but there's always a question of
whether it will hit your credit and from
what I understand from speaking to
attorneys that deal with this it used to
be that if you never gave your social
security number it couldn't hit your
credit and with the gym membership you
usually wouldn't give a social security
number so like your strategy would be
would be one that works I've been told
that even agency or creditors that and a
gym in a sense is a creditor in the
sense that they're crediting you a month
of membership after you've paid or
whatever that they can still hit your
credit even without you ever having
given your social security number I
don't know specifically whether it
applies to gyms but I think people have
to be extra careful with that now in the
gyms defense you did agree to those
terms and the thing that really you did
wrong was that if that wasn't a term
that you agreed to it would have been
useful to note that before you just
signed on to the gym yeah I mean I
understand how that would affect my
credit because I'm not following through
with the contract yes I was just trying
to be sly and find a way around it yet
the man won again I could get used to
him and you're gonna be I guess you'll
be working out at that gym for another
few weeks that's the problem yeah yeah
not a big deal